Before we go, we've got a pick
from the Little Yellow Book and today it comes
from our favorite young Intrepid reporter,
Emmy Eaton, take it away Emmy.
Okay.
So my pick is a podcast called What if World.
It's a podcast for kids.
Each episode is a fun what if story?
Like what if cats ruled the world
or what if a tiny dragon lived in my closet?
Drew, Ross, what would you do if a tiny dragon lived
in your guys' closet?
Move out.
That's what I'd do.
Right?
Yes, renovate.
Just run away.
Go live on the street.
In New York.
I got too much clothes.
Actually, my friend, Dr. Aliza Pressman said
that if a parent is like struggling with their kid
and monsters in their closet,
you can try and make a monster spray.
And put it in.
Right, Drew, if your kids ever have a really messy room,
you could say, well, there's a monster in your closet.
They like it when they it's dirty.
So just clean your room
and then it will not, then they won't be here anymore.
Well, I know what I'll be doing tonight.
Thank you, Emmy for that really great parenting advice.
(everyone laughing)
I really love that What If podcast?
Because if cats ruled the world or.
Or what if Emmy Eaton took over Ross and Drew's job.
That's gonna happen one day.
(everyone laughing)
By the way, I don't doubt it.
I believe it and right here Emmy, right here.
Thank you for joining us at home, or on the go,
or in the studio here with Emmy.
You're time is so precious and we're honored
that you shared it with us.
Thank you!
Take this energy with you.
Bye.
Have a fantastic day.
(upbeat music)